I'm Dr Peter kelmus I'm a climate
scientist and today I'll be answering
questions from Twitter about our planet
this is earth support
[Music]
at underscore Ruth the YY asks I'm so
over this planet are there any planets
out there we can live on yet because
this some bowl no there are no planets
out there that we can live on and that
we can currently get to and Mars totally
sucks it's cold it's a desert there's no
water you're bombarded by radiation that
would give you cancer it's just
basically a cold awful hellscape of a
planet and I love this place I love
Earth and I'm here for Life Adam and J
Panda asks hurricane season starts June
1st so do they just wait until that day
or how does it work hurricanes are
powered by hot ocean water and you get
hotter water in the summertime and in
the fall so that's why late summer fall
is the prime hurricane season at a B
underscore lsoc asks how do satellites
monitor the weather excellent question
so there are two main kinds of weather
satellites you got polar orbiting
satellites which stay in the same
position relative to the Sun as the
Earth rotates underneath them so they'll
sample the planet two times per day once
in the daytime and then once in the
night time descending and then you also
have geostationary satellites which are
looking at the Earth and rotating along
with Earth so they're always seeing the
same thing then there are four main
kinds of sensors on these satellites
you've got Optical imagers which can see
clouds how high the clouds are you have
infrared and microwave Sounders which
together can give you information about
how much moisture there is in the air
columns from the surface of the planet
all the way to the top of the atmosphere
and then finally you have Radars which
can seek rain and snow and other kinds
of water that's falling from the clouds
to the Earth satellites are
indispensable for studying the weather
and the climate at Paul underscore
McGuire asks Cloud physics um what me no
understand Professor yeah so it is one
of the most complicated parts of the
earth system in my opinion and I'm
saying that as somebody who used to
study Cloud physics we understand them
at multiple levels using different kinds
of models if you're looking at get them
with a radar you'll Define it in one way
if you're looking at it with Optical
imagery you might Define the edges of
clouds another way you've got clouds of
different layers the physics works both
on the very smallest scales the tiny
water vapor particles and aerosols that
can nucleate the clouds to the very
largest scales of atmospheric
circulation and these you know huge
weather patterns there's a whole
universe of science just in clouds at
MGS science asks how do global winds and
ocean currents work how does density
play a role so the ultimate driver of
both the ocean currents and the air
currents is the Sun so the Sun hits the
equator it's hotter at the equator much
colder at the at the poles air goes up
from the equator and it heads towards
the poles and it comes down right around
California or Spain so you have Westerly
winds in the subtropics and then in the
equator you have the trade winds which
are coming from the East and going to
the west and the same thing again
remembers happening in the southern
hemisphere the op opposite direction the
ocean Works in a similar way in the
Atlantic you have the Gulf Stream going
up the coast of North America it gets
colder as it gets closer to the poles
colder air is denser it gets saltier as
some of that water on the surface
freezes and that also makes it denser
and that denser water sinks down into
the depths of the ocean and then goes
along the ocean floor back towards the
equator melting water from the Greenland
ice sheet by adding fresh water to the
ocean water the fresh water is less
dense so it doesn't want to sink down
and that could cause potentially that
overturning circulation to change or
maybe even to stop at Kevin Burke 14
asks what is polar amplification again
so very simply when you have ice sheets
covering the Arctic Ocean they're white
they're very bright you look at them
from space and they reflect a lot of
sunlight when that ice melts and goes
away you're left with dark ocean water
which absorbs a lot of sunlight which
makes the planet get even hotter and
more ice Mount at MGR youth asks why is
climate change happening eighty percent
of the global heating that we're
experiencing on the planet today comes
from burning fossil fuels which are
buried carbon coal oil fossil gas that's
locked under our ground we burn that
stuff and each carbon atom combines with
two atoms of oxygen from our atmosphere
to make carbon dioxide CO2 the other 20
comes from methane and this is another
molecule created by animal agriculture
so cows breaking down grasses in their
stomach and then burping out this
methane and nitrous oxide which comes
from fertilizer so this stuff in our air
actually acts like a blanket and means
that more energy from the sun is coming
in than is escaping right now from space
and that makes our planet hotter at
Vijay gagara asks what is the difference
between global warming and climate
change global warming I prefer the term
Global Heating and that is the whole
planet getting hotter every year on
average because of burning fossil fuels
that plant planetary heat causes all of
this chaotic change which we could call
climate change the things like the fires
and the flooding the heat waves and I
prefer the term climate breakdown
because that's what it really feels like
to me where it's not just innocuous
innocent change it's all kind of heading
towards a world that's very different
than the world we're used to and that
our civilization is adapted to at Coffee
jelly 44 asks why is the coral reef
dying bad maybe Earth is on to bigger
and better things I love coral reefs
they're these crazy colorful alien
animals that have solar panels embedded
right in their flesh and coral reefs are
dying around the planet because of ocean
heat waves so just like on lands we're
experiencing worse and worse heat waves
as the planet gets hotter ocean animals
and plants are also experiencing worse
and worse heat waves as the oceans heat
up scientists who study the fossil
record have found that there have been
five previous what we we call mass
extinctions on planet Earth where you
just have a huge dip in biodiversity
because so many species die one of them
was when the dinosaurs died when a giant
asteroid hit the Earth We're in the
sixth mass extinction right now and a
big part of that Extinction uh pressure
is the planet heating up because of
burning fossil fuels and it's true that
after about 10 million years the
biodiversity will recover from this but
there's a whole lot of death and
suffering between now and 10 million
years from now and I firmly believe that
we should do everything we can right now
to stop that death and suffering at usna
73 asks carbon cycle explain please
carbon this uh black atom with 12
protons and 12 electrons the main
component of coal and oil and fossil gas
our bodies are made out of it it's in
the atmosphere it's in trees it's in the
food that we we eat the food it goes in
our body our body breaks the food on
turns it into energy we breathe it out
as carbon dioxide side which goes into
that atmosphere goes into trees again
the cycle continues there are several
reservoirs in the carbon cycle you've
got land plants you've got fossil fuels
you've got the ocean which dissolves
carbon into the water and then you've
got the atmosphere which is like the
Grand Central Station that helps carbon
move between these different reservoirs
all of the transfer of carbon between
these reservoirs was roughly in balance
until quite recently when one species on
this planet decided to dredge up huge
amounts of fossil fuels so carbon from
that fossil fuel Reservoir burn it and
put it into the air Reservoir which is
another way of understanding why the
planet is heating up right now at
furetusa asks just learn that NASA
scientists were arrested for protesting
about climate change and that climate
change is so bad that we only have three
years left to save our planet why am I
not seeing this more well I know of one
NASA climate scientist who got arrested
protesting climate in action and that's
this guy a lot more should do it though
now we do not have just three years to
save the planet how it works is the
longer we burn fossil fuels the worse it
will get this is a planet-wide emergency
but so far world leaders aren't acting
like it the media is not reporting like
it we have to heat our homes we have to
get around on the surface of this planet
but we now have alternatives to do all
that without fossil fuel industry what
we have to do is Sever the influence of
that industry over our politicians and
our media so that we can actually
Implement these Alternatives and in my
opinion that's going to take a really
strong Grassroots movement which is why
I chose to engage in non-violent Civil
Disobedience at a tumulty asks when a
climate alarmist says that agw
anthropogenic global warming is causing
storms to become more violent ask them
what is the actual cause of this a
hotter atmosphere holds more water
that's basic physics every degree is
Centigrade that the atmosphere gets
hotter at seven percent more water which
is actually quite a lot and that means
stronger rainstorms more flooding more
rain he goes on when they say that CO2
is causing the planet to heat up ask
them why does the satellite data show no
net warming in 33 years the satellite
data absolutely and all the other data
sets by the way absolutely show that the
planet is heating up so this shows the
global average surface temperature
Reconstruction from all the thermometers
on the planet and proxies going back to
1880 to the present day and it is a
clear Trend that should be flat that
should not be going up now if you look
at this next plot which shows the global
Ocean Key content and 93 of the excess
energy coming into our Earth is getting
absorbed by the ocean this is perhaps
the fastest Global heating the Earth has
ever experienced that pork fried spice
asks how much longer until Florida is
underwater I've heard that very few
property insurers dare to offer services
there because a problem dramatic climate
forecasting so it depends on what part
of Florida you're talking about the
highest point in Florida is about 350
feet above sea level but there are some
parts of Florida and and some of the
most valuable Parts like Miami Beach
that are just a little bit above sea
level they're already seeing what's
called Sunny Day flooding which is when
there's a high tide you get water in the
streets water in the buildings by 2300
we could expect between maybe 10 feet
and 50 feet of sea level rise depending
on how much of this CO2 we continue to
emit but there's huge uncertainties in
those estimates it could be much worse
than that it's going to keep getting
worse after 2300. at 40 dargas asks how
can air travel be decarbonized is there
an alternative to fossil fuel to fly
planes just wondering not at this time
we can fly planes with batteries but
they only go a couple hundred miles
because you can't store enough energy in
those batteries to lift it up on planes
the batteries are just too heavy the
batteries would have to improve about a
factor of 10 in terms of their energy
density in order to be useful for planes
Crossing oceans another thing you hear
about is biofuels which is basically
running the airplanes on vegetable oil
and that works but there's simply not
enough of it so we can't run commercial
Aviation at its current scale without
fossil fuels at PPH norag asks I'm
genuinely wondering what can I do to
reduce climate change toodles this is a
great question and I think of it in two
categories so first is direct action the
second is what we call individual action
direct action is more important and by
this I mean get really noisy about how
much you want world leaders to act on
climate change and when I say really
noisy I'm also talking about non-violent
Civil Disobedience the second category
is using less fossil fuels yourself the
main thing I did was to end flying so I
haven't flown on the plane since 2012. I
don't want to get on a plane because it
feels really gross to me knowing how
much emissions that plane causes and at
logging on web asks realistically is
there any way we are going to reverse
climate change like are there any
inventions or Solutions in the works to
do this trying to find something
positive in regards to the future of the
planet unfortunately no there is no way
to reverse Global heating now there is
one technology which I think has gotten
overhyped called carbon capture last
year the world's biggest carbon capture
plant climate Works went online in
Iceland with much fanfare they announced
that they could take 4 000 tons of CO2
out of the atmosphere every year if you
do the math that's just three seconds
worth of Humanity's emissions in one
year from one plant you would need 10
million such plants at huge expense to
actually deal with all of Humanity's
emissions to me it's not realistic at
all to think that we're going to reverse
this we need to stop it one of the big
takeaways here is that when we stop
burning fossil fuels the damage will
stop at 11 1 3 asks when will climate
change stop question mark exclamation
mark great question and it has a very
easy answer when we end the fossil fuel
industry and the animal agriculture
Industries at Kristen Smithson asks whoa
chemically how does Methane react in our
atmosphere and how does it affect our
climate that's a great question so
methane is the second biggest cause of
global Heating in terms of the different
molecules in our atmosphere after CO2
it's an interesting molecule one carbon
with four hydrogens once this goes into
the atmosphere it's an extremely
powerful greenhouse gas around 50 times
more powerful than CO2 but it only lasts
roughly 10 years where CO2 stays in the
atmosphere for hundreds or thousands of
years two main ways excess methane is
getting into our atmosphere number one
from Drilling and Mining of fossil fuels
so when you're getting this stuff out of
the ground you get some of this stuff
escaping and leaking into the atmosphere
as well and second from various forms of
Agriculture and food waste decomposition
at Jazzy Jazz Hill asks why can't Cali
be normal for a moment what's up with
this heat upside down smiley face we
have not reached a new normal we are on
an escalator towards hotter and hotter
temperatures worse and worse heat waves
but then you have this extreme drought
which is at least partially caused by
climate change and that's causing you
know water shortages massive wildfires
so the trees don't have enough water to
drink and so they die and then forests
burn very easily so when you have
multiple impacts in one place it just
feels it could feel like Armageddon and
that's exactly what we're seeing in
California and frankly all over the
entire planet on average this is the
hottest summer you've ever experienced
it's also the coolest summer for the
rest of your life so those are all the
questions for today great questions
thanks for your interest in our planet
it's the only one we got and I think
it's pretty important to save it this is
a climate emergency and this was earth
support
[Music]